hey youtubers this Charlie the BBC just
showed his first official trailer for
the 50th anniversary episode let's talk
about what we saw what it means and some
of the things we know about the 50th
anniversary episode so far the clip is
only a minute long and didn't include
any actual footage from the 50th
anniversary episode it did include some
live footage of Matt Smith intercut with
graphics of all the previous doctors it
was really cool mashup with a voiceover
from Smith let me read what it said I've
worked for peace in a universe of war
but now it's time to face the choices
I've made in the name of the doctor on
one impossible day the day I've been
running from my entire life the day of
the doctor so what does this confirm
what does it mean he's basically talking
about the day he stopped the time war
the whatever the awful thing that the
John Hurt doctor did the idea that
they're trying to put forth is is that
whatever that John Hurt doctor did it
was so terrible that all the versions of
the doctor have been come suppressing
the memory of it across time and space
20 says the choices I've made that
really really negative connotation just
kind of implies that the John Hurt
doctor did something that was way worse
than anything that a doctor has ever
done in the history of Doctor Who before
we knew a lot about the John Hurt doctor
he was actually referred to as the dark
doctor though earlier if you haven't
seen it I did a video explaining all the
Easter eggs and the Doctor Who 50th
anniversary poster one of the images was
actually an exploding TARDIS and I
basically kind of connected that
somatically to the series 5 finale the
Big Bang in that episode the doctor and
River blow up the TARDIS to kind of
restart the universe give it like a jump
start and that Easter Egg is connected
to the John Hurt doctor stopping the
time war think about it what could be
worse than destroying the universe to
stop a war obviously it's probably much
more complicated than that
but think about it the TARDIS exists in
all of time and space simultaneously so
if it exploded during the Big Bang it
also exploded during that moment in the
time war and think about it we lovingly
refer to the doctor as the mad doctor
wouldn't it just be a mad doctor's plan
to blow up the universe so here are some
other things that we know about the 50th
anniversary episode so far though number
1 David Tennant and Billie Piper earned
the episode we've known this for a long
time a lot of people have been guessing
based on that 50th anniversary poster
that I just mentioned his haircut is
just a little bit different so people
have been trying to guess about which
version of ten he is obviously he's a
pre end of time 10
because that's the episode where he
regenerates into Matt Smith and the only
regeneration we're going to see in this
episode is John Hurt into the ninth
doctor number two the big bats in the
episode excluding the John Hurt doctor
if you kind of consider him like the
real big bad are the Daleks and the
Zygons we haven't seen the Zygons for
about forty years and they're gonna be a
huge callback to my next thing but
they're basically shapeshifters so I
would expect some characters to be
impersonated in this episode so that
should be a lot of fun number three the
doctor is going to get some help from
unit they were actually featured in that
original Zygons episode forty years ago
the Kate Stewart character is actually
going to be featured in this episode it
was her father who was actually part of
unit in the original Zygons episode so
it's gonna be a huge callback to classic
ooh number four bad wolf this is a big
one so if you remember during series 9
the Rose Tyler bad wolf entity laid a
bunch of clues across time and space to
help Rose Tyler and the doctor defeat
the Daleks
so obviously I'm guessing that the bad
wolf entity in the 50th anniversary
episode will help them solve whatever
John Hurt doctors did and obviously I'm
also expecting Rose Tyler to be featured
as the bad wolf entity in the episode
physically as a side note a big rule of
Doctor Who is that the doctor never
interacts with other versions of himself
directly and obviously that's going to
happen in the 50th anniversary episode
and how does the David Tennant doctor
get into the same time and space as the
John her doctor and the Matt Smith
doctor it could be something that the
bad wolf entity does to ultra-reality to
kind of make that possible
number 5 Peter Davison will be part of
the episode not like the other doctors
he's not going to be a doctor in the
episode but he will either be referenced
or be featured in a small cameo as
another character we don't know quite
how it's going to happen but we know
he's in there and number 6 Peter Capaldi
will not be in the episode as the doctor
it's also possible like the Peter
Davison case that he could have a small
cameo as another character or be
referenced but the first time we'll see
him as the doctor will be the Christmas
special so obviously that's not going to
happen in this episode so there's
anything I didn't mention that you
thought was really important in this
video or my previous 50th anniversary
Easter eggs video be sure to write it in
the comments and we'll discuss if I
there's literally no end to the details
about Doctor Who that we could talk
about in the next several weeks I'll be
doing tons of Doctor Who videos for the
50th anniversary be sure to subscribe to
get them I'm also doing a super special
video collab with the BBC and nurse
I'll give you more info on that video in
the coming weeks but that video won't
actually post til the week before the
50th anniversary episode there's
actually a special Doctor Who
celebration happening on YouTube so I'm
making some special content for that I'm
really excited about but don't worry in
between now and then I'll have tons of
other Doctor Who videos in the meantime
you can click here to watch that 50th
anniversary Easter eggs video that I
mentioned earlier and you can click here
to watch all my Game of Thrones Season 4
previews thanks so much for watching
ilan zzzz high-fives do you all